we continue our series looking at the
challenges and opportunities for
America's infrastructure this evening
correspondent Douglas Kennedy reports on
a new way of going a long way in a short
time
so the Hyperloop is very similar to
space travel as the lead systems
engineer at NASA
Anita Sengupta sent us where no one had
gone before now she's just trying to get
us there faster so this is technology
really out of science fiction
it's technology inspired by science
fiction but it's actually a science fact
it's called Hyperloop or to travel and
will allow humans to go faster than the
fastest high-speed train even faster
than some of the fastest planes in the
sky so you'll be able to get from Kansas
City to st. Louis or New York to
Washington in 30 minutes or less here's
what we're doing is we're targeting a
peak speed of a thousand kilometers per
hour which is roughly 700 miles an hour
the tubes create a low-pressure
environment almost completely cutting
out drag but it's the motor that's going
to allow Hyperloop to completely change
the way we travel so you're basically
designing a straighten out version of a
conventional rotary motor that's correct
so it's called a linear electric motor
and what that means is that you have a
rotor and a stator but they're actually
stretched out so one portion is on the
underside of our vehicle which we call
the pod and the other side is on the
bottom of the track startup costs will
be in the billions nonetheless Missouri
and Colorado both want to be test sites
dan cats is hyper loops government
liaison and he says one of the big
obstacles is writing new regulations for
brand new technology so you've got
pressure systems that are like planes
and land systems that are like trains
who's gonna regulate all of this the
government thinks we're a railroad but
in reality are a lot more like airplanes
no matter what's and Gupta says
Hyperloop is the future of almost
instantaneous travel
have not had a new mode of
transportation in over a hundred years
so this is a way that you can get from
point to point across land massive
across land masses but located within
city centers so you'll be able to skip
that long drive to the airport or train
station in the Nevada desert Douglas
Kennedy Fox News